This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个栏目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都算不上真正安全的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这样做，快来收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的《TWO%》。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||请收听《The Girlfriends》。宝贝，相信我，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和说是个大日子。84 年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost,
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost,|||和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目。不过，正如你可能已经注意到的那样，今天的节目是一期重播。因此，在接下来的两周里，我将播出过去四年中我的一些精选节目，在这几乎不间断的
non-stop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me talking about it, but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book.
non-stop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me talking about it, but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book.|||持续播客创作期间，我将花点时间去推出我的处女作《成长的个体：你二十岁心理学指南》（Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s）。不用担心，我将于 4 月 29 日回归，但我只是想在接下来两周里给我的书多一点关爱，因为这是一件大事，我不会过多谈论它。我确信你来这里只是为了听播客，可能也听腻了我一直在谈论它，但我只想说谢谢。我要非常感谢你们允许我写这本书，
book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. That's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me. So just thank you. Thank you so much.
book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. That's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me. So just thank you. Thank you so much.|||并把它带到这个世界上。这一切之所以可能，完全是因为你们所有人，因为你们这些听众。就是这样。这就是我能够做到这一点的唯一原因。我从五岁起就想成为一名作家，二十年后。是你们帮我实现了这个愿望。所以谢谢你们。非常感谢。
I would obviously love it if you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much. And I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. opportunity. Most of all, I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it. I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love person in progress as well, but it's a really exciting time and the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much. Without further ado, I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through
I would obviously love it if you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much. And I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. opportunity. Most of all, I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it. I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love person in progress as well, but it's a really exciting time and the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much. Without further ado, I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through|||如果你能预定、购买或把它作为礼物送给朋友，我当然会很高兴。但你们已经做得够多了。能有这个机会，我感到非常荣幸。机会。最重要的是，我真的很兴奋能让你们读到它。我希望你们能有所收获。我相信如果你喜欢这个播客，你也会喜欢《成长的个体》（person in progress），但这是一个非常激动人心的时刻，我现在的最大感受就是感激。非常感谢。废话不多说，希望大家喜欢这期我最喜欢的往期节目重播。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客里，我们一起探讨
some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here as always. back for another episode as we dive into the psychology of our 20s. So I want to talk about something today that I have been struggling with recently. You know, I'm just going to jump straight into the point. I don't know about you, but I have been really experiencing this strange sense of just dissatisfaction towards my life recently, a lingering kind of buzzing sense of exhaustion,
some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here as always. back for another episode as we dive into the psychology of our 20s. So I want to talk about something today that I have been struggling with recently. You know, I'm just going to jump straight into the point. I don't know about you, but I have been really experiencing this strange sense of just dissatisfaction towards my life recently, a lingering kind of buzzing sense of exhaustion,|||我们二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到本节目，欢迎回到本播客，新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴能像往常一样在这里迎接大家。欢迎收听新的一期节目，让我们深入探讨二十岁的心理学。所以，我想今天谈谈我最近一直在纠结的一件事。你知道的，我打算直接切入正题。不知道你们怎么样，我最近确实对自己的生活产生了一种奇怪的不满情绪，那种挥之不去的、嗡嗡作响的疲惫感，
and aimlessness, a kind of like a boredom when it comes to. my interests, my future, my relationships, my health, my life in general. It's been really bothering me as someone who is very proactive. When it comes to just like actually enjoying my life, I like feeling excited about things. I like feeling optimistic about the future. And that just hasn't seemed to be the case recently. And I've been really looking into what it might be. The biggest thing for me has been low energy, not being able to kind of show up in my friendships as I would like. I cannot tell you the number of plans. I have cancelled in the last three months.
and aimlessness, a kind of like a boredom when it comes to. my interests, my future, my relationships, my health, my life in general. It's been really bothering me as someone who is very proactive. When it comes to just like actually enjoying my life, I like feeling excited about things. I like feeling optimistic about the future. And that just hasn't seemed to be the case recently. And I've been really looking into what it might be. The biggest thing for me has been low energy, not being able to kind of show up in my friendships as I would like. I cannot tell you the number of plans. I have cancelled in the last three months.|||以及漫无目的感，每当想到我的兴趣、我的未来、我的人际关系、我的健康、我整体的生活时，就会涌起一种类似厌烦的情绪。作为是一个非常积极主动的人，这真的让我很烦恼。当谈到真正享受生活时，我喜欢对事物感到兴奋的感觉。我喜欢对未来保持乐观。但最近似乎并不是这样。我一直在探究这究竟是怎么回事。对我来说，最大的问题是精力不足，无法像我希望的那样在友情中展现最好的自己。我简直无法告诉你，在过去的三个月里我取消了多少个计划。
And I've kind of just reached the conclusion that I have lost my spark a little bit. I've lost the buzz, the love, the thrill for life. And I don't think that I am the only one. You know, our 20s come with a lot of expectations that are hard to ignore. There is so much hype around these being like the best years of your life filled with adventure and sleepless nights and random friendships and relationships and these warm, brilliant memories you'll get to look back on for years to come. And I think maybe this is what we would define as our spark, like an enthusiasm to go out and grab life and to be interested and interesting. our spark is the thing that kind of keeps us passionate about showing up in the world. And it keeps us passionate about who we are and the experiences that we're having.
And I've kind of just reached the conclusion that I have lost my spark a little bit. I'm not feeling the buzz, the love, the thrill for life. And I don't think that I am the only one. You know, our 20s come with a lot of expectations that are hard to ignore. There is so much hype around these being like the best years of your life filled with adventure and sleepless nights and random friendships and relationships and these warm, brilliant memories you'll get to look back on for years to come. And I think maybe this is what we would define as our spark, like an enthusiasm to go out and grab life and to be interested and interesting. our spark is the thing that kind of keeps us passionate about showing up in the world. And it keeps us passionate about who we are and the experiences that we're having.|||我差不多得出了这样的结论：我身上那种闪光点有点消失了。我感受不到那种激情、爱意和对生活的悸动。而且我觉得我不是唯一的一个。你知道的，我们的二十岁伴随着许多难以忽视的期望。关于这段时期是人生中最美好时光的宣传铺天盖地，充满了冒险、不眠之夜、随性的友情和恋爱关系，以及未来几年你回想起来会觉得温暖而美好的回忆。我想这也许就是我们所定义的闪光点，就像一种走出去拥抱生活的热情，对事物感兴趣并且让自己变得有趣。我们的闪光点正是那种让我们对在这个世界上展现自我保持激情的东西。它让我们对自我以及我们正在经历的体验保持热情。
It's what makes us inspired and kind and engaged and motivated and present. But we can't be that all the time. You can't really be living in the golden bubble every minute of every day. there will come a time, as I guess I'm experiencing right now as we speak, where the energy and the excitement for life kind of dips. You become very detached from that person that you love, that person that you are at your core, and everything around you seems to lose a bit of color. You lose that kind of energy that you bring into conversations, that energy that you bring into your daily life. And for me, I've been really reflecting on this, and I've been thinking about the person I want to,
It's what makes us inspired and kind and engaged and motivated and present. But we can't be that all the time. You can't really be living in the golden bubble every minute of every day. there will come a time, as I guess I'm experiencing right now as we speak, where the energy and the excitement for life kind of dips. You become very detached from that person that you love, that person that you are at your core, and everything around you seems to lose a bit of color. You lose that kind of energy that you bring into conversations, that energy that you bring into your daily life. And for me, I've been really reflecting on this, and I've been thinking about the person I want to,|||正是它让我们受到启发、心存善意、全身心投入、充满动力并活在当下。但我们不可能永远都这样。你不可能每时每刻都生活在金色的气泡里。总会有一个时刻——就像我此刻正在经历的那样——对生活的精力和热情会开始下降。你会与你所爱的那个人、与你内心的那个自己变得非常疏离，你周围的一切似乎都失去了色彩。你失去了那种带入对话中的活力，失去了那种带入日常生活中的能量。对我而言，我一直在深刻反思这一点，我一直在想我想成为
was three or four years ago who just seemed so in love with life and really wondering where she's gone, whether I can get her back, but also whether I want her back or whether it's just a general disconnection. So we're going to talk about that today. I want to talk about why we lose our spark, why it is such a common experience, the reasons behind that. It may be burnout, it may have been a breakup, but then also six tips for regaining that motivation and that love for life. Losing your spark could be for a number of reasons, but there are four main explanations that I think stand out to me, especially in our 20s. The first, the biggest one really, is burnout, pushing ourselves too hard for too long and ignoring the warning signs that we need rest.
was three or four years ago who just seemed so in love with life and really wondering where she's gone, whether I can get her back, but also whether I want her back or whether it's just a general disconnection. So we're going to talk about that today. I want to talk about why we lose our spark, why it is such a common experience, the reasons behind that. It may be burnout, it may have been a breakup, but then also six tips for regaining that motivation and that love for life. Losing your spark could be for a number of reasons, but there are four main explanations that I think stand out to me, especially in our 20s. The first, the biggest one really, is burnout, pushing ourselves too hard for too long and ignoring the warning signs that we need rest.|||三四年前的那个女孩，她当时看起来是那么热爱生活，我真的很想知道她去哪了，我是否能找回她，但我也在想我是否真的想找回她，还是说这只是一种普遍的疏离感。所以我们今天就要聊聊这个。我想谈谈为什么我们会失去生活的热情，为什么这是一种如此普遍的经历，以及背后的原因。可能是职业倦怠，可能是刚经历了一场分手，但同时也会分享六个重新找回动力和对生活的热爱的建议。失去热情可能有多种原因，但我认为有四个主要的解释格外引人注目，尤其是在我们的二十岁时。第一个，也是最大的一个原因，其实就是职业倦怠，我们对自己逼得太紧、持续时间太久，却忽视了我们需要休息的警告信号。
and we need time to actually process our lives, our emotions and all the activity that is going on. We're seeing a lot of research that burnout is becoming a lot more common during this day and age, especially amongst people under the age of 30. Now, I think the reason for this is twofold. Number one, we're obviously quite new to the workplace, but also new to life. we don't really know or aren't able to express our limits, our points of exhaustion. But secondly, I think it's because of this expectation to be doing everything, to be constantly and always aiming for more.
and we need time to actually process our lives, our emotions and all the activity that is going on. We're seeing a lot of research that burnout is becoming a lot more common during this day and age, especially amongst people under the age of 30. Now, I think the reason for this is twofold. Number one, we're obviously quite new to the workplace, but also new to life. we don't really know or aren't able to express our limits, our points of exhaustion. But secondly, I think it's because of this expectation to be doing everything, to be constantly and always aiming for more.|||并且我们需要时间来真正处理我们的生活、我们的情感以及正在发生的所有事情。我们看到大量研究表明，在这个时代，职业倦怠变得越来越普遍，尤其是在 30 岁以下的人群中。现在，我认为原因有两个方面。第一，我们显然刚踏入职场不久，对生活也还很陌生。我们并不真正了解或者无法表达自己的极限、我们的精疲力竭点。但其次，我认为这是因为人们有一种期望，即必须做好每件事，必须不断地、永远追求更多。
You have to be focused at school or in your job whilst also having a lot of fulfilling friendships and then hobbies and a loving relationship and perfect physical and mental health whilst also been able to, you know, juggle your family and a side hustle. and your own needs. If that feels impossible to you, you are not the only one. Each of us has an individual threshold for how much stress, activity, mental exhaustion that we can tolerate. And I think as we slowly reach that threshold, we start sacrificing elements of our well-being
You have to be focused at school or in your job whilst also having a lot of fulfilling friendships and then hobbies and a loving relationship and perfect physical and mental health whilst also been able to, you, know, juggle your family and a side hustle. and your own needs. If that feels impossible to you, you are not the only one. Each of us has an individual threshold for how much stress, activity, mental exhaustion that we can tolerate. And I think as we slowly reach that threshold, we start sacrificing elements of our well-being|||你必须在学校或工作专心致志，同时还要维持许多充实的友情，接着是培养爱好、谈一场充满爱意的恋爱，保持完美的身体和心理健康，与此同时还要能兼顾家庭、副业以及你自己的需求。如果这对你来说是不可能的任务，你并不孤单。我们每个人对于所能承受的压力、活动量和精神消耗都有一个独特的阈值。我想，当我们慢慢接近那个阈值时，我们便开始牺牲我们福祉中的种种元素，
to keep up with what is expected of us and what we expect from ourselves. and that includes very tangible things like sleep, self-care, exercise, downtime. Those are normally the first things to go when we're burnt out. And also more intangible things like mental rest, thinking time, a space for imagination and creativity. You need all of these things to keep your spark a light. It's hard to prioritize the things that make you excited for life, the small joys or even the energy for the big things, if you are struggling with prolonged, you know, prolonged exhaustion,
to keep up with what is expected of us and what we expect from ourselves. and that includes very tangible things like sleep, self-care, exercise, downtime. Those are normally the first things to go when we're burnt out. And also more intangible things like mental rest, thinking time, a space for imagination and creativity. You need all of these things to keep your spark a light. It's hard to prioritize the things that make you excited for life, the small joys or even the energy for the big things, if you are struggling with prolonged, you know, prolonged exhaustion,|||去迎合别人对我们的期望以及我们对自己的期望。这包括非常具体的事情，比如睡眠、自我关照、锻炼和休闲时间。当我们精疲力竭时，这些通常是最先被舍弃的东西。还有一些更无形的东西，比如精神上的休息、思考的时间、想象力和创造力的空间。你需要所有这些东西来让你的热情之火常燃。如果你正在经历长期的、你知道的，长期的精疲力竭，你就很难优先去关注那些让你对生活感到兴奋的事情、生活中的小确幸，甚至是没有精力去应付那些大事，
prolonged fatigue, burnout from a lack of work-life balance, or kind of academic or personal overload. We are seeing so much of this recently and it also is demonstrating a lot of links to an increased vulnerability to illness, increased feelings of pessimism, inadequacy, none of which I think, seem to go hand in hand with feeling like yourself or feeling like your spark is a light and alive. So the second factor that I think contributes to losing our spark is a lingering or pre-existent mental health disorder or challenge that may be getting out of control or becoming a little bit unmanageable, whether that is anxiety, depression, ADHD, some other condition. when it impacts our cognitions, our mood, our emotions, this condition is going to impact our so-called spark
prolonged fatigue, burnout from a lack of work-life balance, or kind of academic or personal overload. We are seeing so much of this recently and it also is demonstrating a lot of links to an increased vulnerability to illness, increased feelings of pessimism, inadequacy, none of which I think, seem to go hand in hand with feeling like yourself or feeling like your spark is a light and alive. So the second factor that I think contributes to losing our spark is a lingering or pre-existent mental health disorder or challenge that may be getting out of control or becoming a little bit unmanageable, whether that is anxiety, depression, ADHD, some other condition. when it impacts our cognitions, our mood, our emotions, this condition is going to impact our so-called spark|||长期的疲劳、由于缺乏工作生活平衡导致的职业倦怠，或是某种学业或个人负担过重。我们最近看到了太多这样的情况，这也表明它与患病风险的增加、悲观情绪的增加以及无能感之间存在许多联系，而我认为，这些情况似乎都无法与“找回自我”或“感觉内心的火花依然明亮且充满活力”联系在一起。因此，我认为导致我们失去热情的第二个因素是挥之不去或本已存在的心理健康障碍或挑战，这些问题可能正在失控或变得有些难以掌控，无论是焦虑、抑郁、多动症（ADHD），还是其他某种状况。当它影响我们的认知、情绪和情感时，这种状况就会影响我们所谓的激情与活力，
and most importantly our way of relating to the world. So many factors impact this and sometimes there really isn't an explanation for why your mental health is suddenly not as good. But I don't think anyone really talks about how physically tiring it is to have to put 100% of your energy into just convincing yourself to do even the smallest of tasks. I think maintaining your spark and all the activities that promote this part of you is a luxury when you're just trying to get by day by day. The third contributing factor, I think, is not spending enough time with your own thoughts
and most importantly our way of relating to the world. So many factors impact this and sometimes there really isn't an explanation for why your mental health is suddenly not as good. But I don't think anyone really talks about how physically tiring it is to have to put 100% of your energy into just convincing yourself to do even the smallest of tasks. I think maintaining your spark and all the activities that promote this part of you is a luxury when you're just trying to get by day by day. The third contributing factor, I think, is not spending enough time with your own thoughts|||最重要的是，它会影响我们与世界相处的方式。有太多因素会影响这一点，有时真的很难解释为什么你的心理健康状况突然就变差了。但我认为没有人真正讨论过，把 100% 的精力都花在说服自己去完成哪怕最小的任务上，是一件多么让人筋疲力尽的事情。我认为，当你只是在勉强度日时，维持你的热情以及所有能促进你这部分自我的活动，简直是一种奢侈。我认为，导致这一结果的第三个因素是，没有花足够的时间与自己的想法相处，
or operating from a place of external validation. I think when we live for others, how are we really meant to pull from that internal source of meaning and passion and mission. How are we meant to feel like ourselves when we are engaging in extreme people pleasing? When we do feel unnecessarily guilty for other people's emotions or feelings, when we say yes when we really want to say no, when we have no social boundaries, when we take on others' opinions or try and impress people at the expense of our own mental health,
or operating from a place of external validation. I think when we live for others, how are we really meant to pull from that internal source of meaning and passion and mission. How are we meant to feel like ourselves when we are engaging in extreme people pleasing? When we do feel unnecessarily guilty for other people's emotions or feelings, when we say yes when we really want to say no, when we have no social boundaries, when we take on others' opinions or try and impress people at the expense of our own mental health,|||或是基于外部认可来行事。我认为，当我们为他人而活时，我们又如何能从那个内在的意义、热情和使命源泉中汲取力量呢？当我们陷入极端的取悦症时，我们又怎么能感觉像真正的自己呢？当我们为别人的情绪或感受感到不必要的内疚时，当我们明明想说“不”却说“好”时，当我们毫无社交边界感时，当我们为了迎合别人的意见或试图给别人留下深刻印象而牺牲自己的心理健康时，
if our spark is cultivated from our own internal mental energy source, from being connected and attached and knowledgeable about who we are, when all of that time is devoted to thinking about others, that part of us becomes neglected. And the final factor, this one is a little bit different from what we've just spoken about, but it is the end of a relationship. I really do see that as a catalyst,
if our spark is cultivated from our own internal mental energy source, from being connected and attached and knowledgeable about who we are, when all of that time is devoted to thinking about others, that part of us becomes neglected. And the final factor, this one is a little bit different from what we've just spoken about, but it is the end of a relationship. I really do see that as a catalyst,|||如果我们的激情是由我们内在的精神能量源泉所培养的，源于我们与自我建立的联系、依恋以及对自我的了解，那么当所有这些时间都用来为他人着想时，我们内心的这一部分就会被忽视。最后一个因素，这个因素与我们刚才谈到的略有不同，但它是一段关系的结束。我真的认为这是一个催化剂，
for losing a little bit of your passion and your, just your passion and your love for who you are and your love for life and the energy that you bring into literally just your daily activities. So when we lose a relationship, whether that is with a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a really close friend, that creates a massive shift in us. It is a complete severance from part of the person. of ourselves that was connected to this other person. It would often, I would say, also trigger a really significant dip in self-esteem, feeling very lost, because we attach so much of our identity to those we love. You know, they hold us up. They make us feel seen. They bear witness to our lives.
for losing a little bit of your passion and your, just your passion and your love for who you are and your love for life and the energy that you bring into literally just your daily activities. So when we lose a relationship, whether that is with a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a really close friend, that creates a massive shift in us. It is a complete severance from part of the person. of ourselves that was connected to this other person. It would often, I would say, also trigger a really significant dip in self-esteem, feeling very lost, because we attach so much of our identity to those we love. You know, they hold us up. They make us feel seen. They bear witness to our lives.|||会让你失去一点激情，对你是谁的热爱，对生活的热爱，以及你倾注在日常生活中的活力。因此，当我们失去一段关系时，无论是与男朋友、女朋友还是非常要好的朋友，这都会在我们身上产生巨大的转变。这是对我们自己与另一个人相连的那部分人格的一次彻底割裂。我想，这通常也会引发自尊心的急剧下降，让人感到非常迷失，因为我们将太多的自我认同寄托在我们所爱的人身上。你知道的，他们支撑着我们。他们让我们觉得自己被看见。他们见证了我们的生活。
But they can also, I think, cause us a lot of heartache and a lot of disruption when relationships like this end, often because there comes a moment of complacency. So I think when we are in a long-term relationship or we are in this long-term dependent friendship, sometimes we become very, it becomes very easy to just fall into only seeing them, to only hanging out with them, to sitting, watching TV with them, to not exploring other parts of you. So when that relationship suddenly ends, you kind of experience an emotional vacuum. where you have incidentally, accidentally, involuntarily given up parts of you for this relationship,
But they can also, I think, cause us a lot of heartache and a lot of disruption when relationships like this end, often because there comes a moment of complacency. So I think when we are in a long-term relationship or we are in this long-term dependent friendship, sometimes we become very, it becomes very easy to just fall into only seeing them, to only hanging out with them, to sitting, watching TV with them, to not exploring other parts of you. So when that relationship suddenly ends, you kind of experience an emotional vacuum. where you have incidentally, accidentally, involuntarily given up parts of you for this relationship,|||但我也认为，当这样的关系结束时，它们也会给我们带来许多心碎和许多动荡，这通常是因为此时会出现一段自满的时期。所以我想，当我们处于一段长期的恋爱关系中，或者处于这种长期的依附性友谊中时，有时我们会变得非常、非常容易陷入只看到对方的境地，只和他们混在一起，和他们坐在一起看电视，而不再去探索你身上的其他部分。因此，当这段关系突然结束时，你就会经历一种情感上的真空。在这个过程中，你为了这段关系，无意中、偶然地、不由自主地放弃了自我的一部分，
for the ease of this relationship, and when you come out of it, you don't really know who you are. You don't really know what the future holds. You don't really know what it means to be you without them. And I think that is a huge catalyst, as I said, for feeling a sense of dislocation, and disconnection from what makes you you and from your spark. It also just reveals so much about what we have perhaps been neglecting in our lives, the parts of ourselves that have become secondary behind the relationship. Maybe one of these explanations, one of these situations is calling to you.
for the ease of this relationship, and when you come out of it, you don't really know who you are. You don't really know what the future holds. You don't really know what it means to be you without them. And I think that is a huge catalyst, as I said, for feeling a sense of dislocation, and disconnection from what makes you you and from your spark. It also just reveals so what we have perhaps been neglecting in our lives, the parts of ourselves that have become secondary behind the relationship. Maybe one of these explanations, one of these situations is calling to you.|||为了这段关系的省心，而当你从中走出来时，你其实并不知道自己是谁。你并不真正知道未来会怎样。你真的不知道没有了他们，做自己意味着什么。正如我所说，我认为这是一个巨大的催化剂，会让人产生一种错位感，并与造就独特自我以及内心激情的东西产生隔阂。它也揭示了我们在生活中可能一直在忽视的东西，即那些在关系背后沦为次要地位的自我的部分。也许这些解释中的某一个，或者这些情况中的某一种，正在呼唤着你。
You can really see yourself in these examples. Maybe you just feel like there's just something missing. None of these really apply. There's just a genuine lack of, lack of, a sense of effort to be put into your life. It doesn't really matter because I think that what is most important here is that right now you are having this experience that makes you feel like your life is less than optimal and that there is something that you're missing out on and missing out of getting from your life. So I'm going to talk about six research-based tips to get your spark back,
You can really see yourself in these examples. Maybe you just feel like there's just something missing. None of these really apply. There's just a genuine lack of, lack of, a sense of effort to be put into your life. It doesn't really matter because I think that what is most important here is that right now you are having this experience that makes you feel like your life is less than optimal and that there is something that you're missing out on and missing out of getting from your life. So I'm going to talk about six research-based tips to get your spark back,|||你真的能在这些例子中看到自己的影子。也许你只是觉得有什么地方不对劲。这些都不太适用。只是纯粹缺乏、缺乏将精力投入生活的动力。这其实并不重要，因为我认为这里最重要的是，此时此刻你正在经历这种体验，它让你觉得你的生活并不在最佳状态，你正错过某些东西，错过了从生活中获得的东西。因此，我将讨论基于研究的六个建议，教你如何找回生活的热情，
starting with the most simple but the most important after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
starting with the most simple but the most important after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.|||从最简单但也最重要的一点开始，休息一下广告马上回来。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信植物油天生具有致炎性。我们大错特错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?|||世界上许多让我们感到恐慌的问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO% 播客。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 MTV VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Little Kim）胸部的那个场景吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.|||好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过那段时期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要说明的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.|||我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿其中的主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了对于黑人而言。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on that. iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we
Listen to look back at it on that. iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的心理治疗师 Kear Games。为了迎接心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多令人惊叹的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于
don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Keer games is we have real conversations about healing growth Powerhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Keer games is we have real conversations about healing growth Powerhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.|||没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在看记分牌，生活变成了关于输赢的游戏——史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是说你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟，绝对是，那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人，和我 Kear Games 一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、男子气概、压力和人生目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.|||搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023 年，前《钻石单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。L.桑兹女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.|||阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《情感陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. that Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You need to replenish your body and your mind before you can start building back your interest in life. That is why the biggest thing for getting your spark back is prioritizing rest. It sounds so simple, but we really don't acknowledge how much of a difference a good night's sleep or a week off can be for resetting our body, especially when this becomes a practice of scheduling time to do nothing of scheduling time to just relax in your body, in your mind and be present.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. that Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You need to replenish your body and your mind before you can start building back your interest in life. That is why the biggest thing for getting your spark back is prioritizing rest. It sounds so simple, but we really don't acknowledge how much of a difference a good night's sleep or a week off can be for resetting our body, especially when this becomes a practice of scheduling time to do nothing of scheduling time to just relax in your body, in your mind and be present.|||随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县（Maricopa County）劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。在开始重新培养对生活的兴趣之前，你需要先补充体力和精神。这就是为什么找回生活热情最重要的一点是将休息放在首位。听起来很简单，但我们真的没有意识到，一个好觉或一周的假期对于重置我们的身体能有多大改观，尤其是当这变成了一种习惯——安排时间什么都不做，安排时间让身体和心灵完全放松并活在当下。
When you've pushed yourself to this cliff edge of complete exhaustion, you reach a point of internal dish whereby your body will literally start to shut down. due to ongoing chronic stress. That doesn't sound optimal and it certainly doesn't help with getting your spark back. Sometimes we think that we need to be doing more to be more, but it's actually quite the opposite. The people who know themselves the best and get the most out of life are those who realize the value in giving their brain and their body, even their soul, time to replenish. if you've lost your spark you need to start by reintroducing rest back into your life and this includes by doing things like taking your sick days when you need them without feeling like you need to justify it
When you've pushed yourself to this cliff edge of complete exhaustion, you reach a point of internal dish whereby your body will literally start to shut down. due to ongoing chronic stress. That doesn't sound optimal and it certainly doesn't help with getting your spark back. Sometimes we think that we need to be doing more to be more, but it's actually quite the opposite. The people who know themselves the best and get the most out of life are those who realize the value in giving their brain and their body, even their soul, time to replenish. if you've lost your spark you need to start by reintroducing rest back into your life and this includes by doing things like taking your sick days when you need them without feeling like you need to justify it|||当你把自己逼到精疲力竭的悬崖边缘时，你就会达到一种内在失调的状态，由于长期的慢性压力，你的身体实际上会开始崩溃。这听起来可不是什么好状态，而且对于找回生活热情也绝对毫无帮助。有时我们认为我们需要做更多的事来成为更优秀的人，但事实恰恰相反。那些最了解自己并从生活中收获最多的人，往往是那些意识到给大脑和身体、甚至灵魂留出时间来休养生息的价值所在的人。如果你失去了热情，你需要从将休息重新引入生活开始，这包括在需要时请病假，而不需要觉得有必要为此解释一番，
being okay with saying no to plans to just chill at home giving yourself a day every now and again to just do nothing it's those slow moments that our brain finally gets to switch off and you'll really be surprised about how much comes up for you, how many ideas, plans for the future, helpful thoughts arise because you finally have space to hold them in space to process them. I really do understand that it's actually quite hard to do that and accept that we need to slow down. We feel a lot of guilt towards rest because of the societal association with laziness. If you are not pushing yourself 100% of the time. If you don't want to do it all, it's because you just lack discipline. It's because you're just lazy rather than actually listening to your body and recognizing that this is actually
being okay with saying no to plans to just chill at home giving yourself a day every now and again to just do nothing it's those slow moments that our brain finally gets to switch off and you'll really be surprised about how much comes up for you, how many ideas, plans for the future, helpful thoughts arise because you finally have space to hold them in space to process them. I really do understand that it's actually quite hard to do that and accept that we need to slow down. We feel a lot of guilt towards rest because of the societal association with laziness. If you are not pushing yourself 100% of the time. If you don't want to do it all, it's because you just lack discipline. It's because you're just lazy rather than actually listening to your body and recognizing that this is actually|||接受对那些计划说“不”并选择宅在家里放松的做法，偶尔给自己一天时间什么也不做，正是通过这些慢下来的时刻，我们的大脑终于得以关机，你会惊讶地发现有多少灵感涌现，有多少对未来的计划、有用的想法会冒出来，因为你终于有了空间去容纳它们，有空间去处理它们。我确实理解，要做到这一点并接受我们需要放慢脚步其实相当困难。由于社会将休息与懒惰联系在一起，我们对休息感到十分内疚。如果你没有百分之百地逼迫自己。如果你不想把所有事情都做好，那是因为你缺乏纪律性。这是因为你只是懒惰，而不是真正倾听身体的声音并认识到这其实是
more efficient. I think these attitudes are especially pervasive if you're an overachiever, or if you put a lot of worth into your external achievements, resetting your attitude towards rest kind of means unlearning everything that brings you a sense of personal fulfillment or satisfaction, like your achievements, like being somebody who can push themselves, being somebody who enjoys the urgency of exhaustion. That is just not sustainable though. And it causes you to neglect the parts of you that you need for, that your future self really needs.
more efficient. I think these attitudes are especially pervasive if you're an overachiever, or if you put a lot of worth into your external achievements, resetting your attitude towards rest kind of means unlearning everything that brings you a sense of personal fulfillment or satisfaction, like your achievements, like being somebody who can push themselves, being somebody who enjoys the urgency of exhaustion. That is just not sustainable though. And it causes you to neglect the parts of you that you need for, that your future self really needs.|||更有效率的方式。我认为，如果你是个追求极致完美的人，或者你把很多价值寄托在外在成就上，这种态度尤其普遍。重塑你对休息的态度，在某种程度上意味着抛弃所有带给你个人成就感或满足感的事物，比如你的成就，比如做一个能够逼迫自己的人，做一个享受筋疲力竭的紧迫感的人。然而，这根本是不可持续的。它会让你忽视自己所需的那部分自我，忽视你未来的自己真正需要的东西。
You know, it needs you to stay strong and to stay healthy. Your soul, your sense of self, needs. you to actually stop and pause and focus on who you are and what you're getting out of life. I think rest also just really increases our capacity for self-awareness. It improves our empathy. It improves our ability to imagine the future. So I think that it gives us a real creative and prospective vision for who we are and what we want. And in turn, really gives us our life back.
You know, it needs you to stay strong and to stay healthy. Your soul, your sense of self, needs. you to actually stop and pause and focus on who you are and what you're getting out of life. I think rest also just really increases our capacity for self-awareness. It improves our empathy. It improves our ability to imagine the future. So I think that it gives us a real creative and prospective vision for who we are and what we want. And in turn, really gives us our life back.|||你知道的，它需要你保持坚强和健康。你的灵魂、你的自我意识，需要你真正停下来，暂停一下，专注于你是谁以及你从生活中得到了什么。我认为休息也确实增强了我们的自我意识能力。它提高了我们的同理心。它提高了我们想象未来的能力。因此，我认为它为我们提供了关于“我们是谁”以及“我们想要什么”的真正具有创造性和前瞻性的愿景。反过来，它也真正把生活还给了我们。
So my second tip for getting your spark back is to shift. from a passive agent to an active agent in your life. So often the reason we lose our spark is because we settle into living as though we are on autopilot. I want you to pause and think whether that's you. Things happen to us. Life happens to us. We just kind of accept that that's the way it is. We aren't doing much steering when it comes to our decisions, to what might make us happier, to avoiding or changing circumstances that are depleting us. And it is a lot easier to live life this way. It's really tiring to have to wake up each moment and live with the fact that you are creating your reality, that you are creating your future, you are in control, you have agency.
So my second tip for getting your spark back is to shift. from a passive agent to an active agent in your life. So often the reason we lose our spark is because we settle into living as though we are on autopilot. I want you to pause and think whether that's you. Things happen to us. Life happens to us. We just kind of accept that that's the way it is. We aren't doing much steering when it comes to our decisions, to what might make us happier, to avoiding or changing circumstances that are depleting us. And it is a lot easier to live life this way. It's really tiring to have to wake up each moment and live with the fact that you are creating your reality, that you are creating your future, you are in control, you have agency.|||所以，找回热情的第二个建议是转变角色：从你生活中的被动接受者转变为主动掌控者。我们常常失去热情，是因为我们习惯了像开启自动驾驶一样生活。我希望你停下来想一想，这说的是不是你。事情发生在我们身上。生活降临在我们身上。我们只是默默接受了现状就是如此。在做出决定时，我们并没有做出太多掌控，没有去思考什么能让我们更快乐，也没有去避免或改变那些消耗我们的境况。以这种方式生活要轻松得多。每天醒来都要面对这样一个事实：你正在创造自己的现实，你正在创造自己的未来，你在掌控一切，你拥有自主权——这真的很累。
Because that kind of awareness of your responsibility is naturally more effort, right? It takes a lot more from you. But I honestly believe that that expenditure of effort pays off in its thousands and becomes easier, becomes less taxing when we adjust to a way of living that actually gives us what we want in the long term, rather than like the instant gratification, small pleasures in the short term. It's so much more exhausting living every day at 60% and dragging the other 40% behind you then at 100% and seeing yourself really have purpose and passion and come back into your life, getting your spark back. Now, this isn't to say that you should be working harder, doing more, 100% effort, 100% energy
Because that kind of awareness of your responsibility is naturally more effort, right? It takes a lot more from you. But I honestly believe that that expenditure of effort pays off in its thousands and becomes easier, becomes less taxing when we adjust to a way of living that actually gives us what we long term, rather than like the instant gratification, small pleasures in the short term. It's so much more exhausting living every day at 60% and dragging the other 40% behind you then at 100% and seeing yourself really have purpose and passion and come back into your life, getting your spark back. Now, this isn't to say that you should be working harder, doing more, 100% effort, 100% energy|||因为这种对责任的觉知自然需要付出更多努力，对吧？它会从你身上索取更多。但我真心相信，这种努力的付出会有千百倍的回报，并且当我们调整到一种真正能在长期内给我们想要的东西的生活方式时，它会变得更容易、负担更轻，而不是像短期的即时满足和小快乐那样。每天以 60% 的状态生活，拖着另外 40% 的疲惫前行，要比以 100% 的状态生活、看到自己真正拥有目标和热情并重新融入生活、找回热情要疲惫得多。现在，这并不是说你应该更努力工作、做更多事情、付出 100% 的努力、100% 的精力，
all the time, right? Because I think that is a contribution to pure exhaustion, which we know is a contributor to burnout. Rather, it's about choosing to live light versus live heavy. when we live heavy, we kind of borrow effort and time from our future selves. I'm going to explain this a little bit more. When you don't make active choices about what's going to make your life better, whether that is choosing to fuel your body in a way that feels good, choosing to rest when you need, choosing to turn off your screen before bed,
all the time, right? Because I think that is a contribution to pure exhaustion, which we know is a contributor to burnout. Rather, it's about choosing to live light versus live heavy. when we live heavy, we kind of borrow effort and time from our future selves. I'm going to explain this a little bit more. When you don't make active choices about what's going to make your life better, whether that is choosing to fuel your body in a way that feels good, choosing to rest when you need, choosing to turn off your screen before bed,|||时刻紧绷，对吧？因为我认为那只会导致纯粹的筋疲力竭，而我们知道这正是职业倦怠的诱因。相反，这是关于选择轻装上阵还是负重前行。当我们负重前行时，我们其实是在向未来的自己借用精力和时间。我再稍微解释一下这一点。当你没有就什么能让你的生活变得更好做出主动选择时——无论是选择以一种感觉良好的方式为身体补充能量、在需要时选择休息、还是选择在睡前关闭屏幕，
even though you want to scroll for a few more minutes, choosing to keep good company, you transfer all of those decisions into your future. as consequences. In the short term, you've got to live life because you made the easiest decision to stay in bed rather than work out or see friends to spend that extra 30 minutes on your phone in bed rather than reading a book to sacrifice your sleep, to put things off when they would seriously only take about five minutes. You're stealing joy from your future self and contributing to exhaustion by taking what seems like the easier route but in the long term is the harder
even though you want to scroll for a few more minutes, choosing to keep good company, you transfer all of those decisions into your future. as consequences. In the short term, you've got to live life because you made the easiest decision to stay in bed rather than work out or see friends to spend that extra 30 minutes on your phone in bed rather than reading a book to sacrifice your sleep, to put things off when they would seriously only take about five minutes. You're stealing joy from your future self and contributing to exhaustion by taking what seems like the easier route but in the long term is the harder|||尽管你还想多刷几分钟手机——或者选择结交良友，你其实是将所有这些决定都转化为了未来的后果。从短期来看，你必须得过且过，因为你做出了最轻松的决定：赖在床上而不是去锻炼或见朋友，在床上多玩 30 分钟手机而不是去看书，牺牲睡眠时间，把那些明明只要五分钟就能搞定的事情一拖再拖。你选择了一条看似容易、但从长远来看更艰难的道路，这实际上是在窃取未来自己的快乐，并加剧了自身的疲惫。
route. I think good practices fulfilling life habits are tiring, but they do actually give you a sense of control over your life and give you a sense that you actually get to do the things you want to do and create a life you want to live and actually create meaning within that life, meaning that when you show up every single day, when you wake up, you have the energy in the space to be yourself, to show love to yourself to get your spark back by actively engaging in decisions that are all devoted to bettering you and to making your life easier. I think at the end of the day, what this shift from passive to active entails is noticing the things that deplete your energy versus create energy for you, things that unsettle you
route. I think good practices fulfilling life habits are tiring, but they do actually give you a sense of control over your life and give you a sense that you actually get to do the things you want to do and create a life you want to live and actually create meaning within that life, meaning that when you show up every single day, when you wake up, you have the energy in the space to be yourself, to show love to yourself to get your spark back by actively engaging in decisions that are all devoted to bettering you and to making your life easier. I think at the end of the day, what this shift from passive to active entails is noticing the things that deplete your energy versus create energy for you, things that unsettle you|||我认为良好的习惯、充实的生活习惯确实很累人，但它们确实能让你对自己的生活有一种掌控感，让你觉得你真的能去做自己想做的事，创造你想过的生活，并在那种生活中创造意义。这意味着当你每天出现、当你醒来时，你有精力和空间去做自己，去关爱自己，通过积极参与那些致力于完善自我、让生活更轻松的决策来找回生活的热情。我认为归根结底，从被动转向主动意味着去注意那些消耗你能量的事情与为你创造能量的事情之间的区别，去注意那些让你感到不安的事物，
versus comfort you, things that make you fatigued, make you tired, make you sad versus things that make you energized and excited and joyful. That's the first step. I think the second step is like really consciously choosing the alternative to those energy takers in your life. You typically, I think, see a difficulty curve occur here. For example, if you're big thing for making your life easier or living light is choosing to do a creative project before bed rather than just mindlessly watch TV.
versus comfort you, things that make you fatigued, make you tired, make you sad versus things that make you energized and excited and joyful. That's the first step. I think the second step is like really consciously choosing the alternative to those energy takers in your life. You typically, I think, see a difficulty curve occur here. For example, if you're big thing for making your life easier or living light is choosing to do a creative project before bed rather than just mindlessly watch TV.|||与那些安慰你的事物，那些让你疲惫、劳累、悲伤的事物，与那些让你充满活力、兴奋和喜悦的事物。这是第一步。我认为第二步是有意识地选择生活中那些能量吸血鬼的替代品。我认为通常在这里你会看到一个难度曲线。例如，如果你让生活更轻松或轻装上阵的重大举措是选择在睡前做一个创意项目，而不是盲目地看电视。
it's always going to be hard at the beginning because I think that we become very adjusted and very comfortable in what is familiar and what is easy and any shift or change to that kind of life structure, life routine. It's going to disrupt that norm. But over time as you adjust, you'll see that it becomes a lot more kind of habitual and automatic to do the thing that is best for you and to do the thing that helps you get your spark back that did the thing that really involves showing yourself a lot of radical self-compassion by not giving into your immediate wants but focusing on your long-term well-being. My next tip is perhaps my favorite and this involves getting back to that place of passion,
it's always going to be hard at the beginning because I think that we become very adjusted and very comfortable in what is familiar and what is easy and any shift or change to that kind of life structure, life routine. It's going to disrupt that norm. But over time as you adjust, you'll see that it becomes a lot more kind of habitual and automatic to do the thing that is best for you and to do the thing that helps you get your spark back that did the thing that really involves showing yourself a lot of radical self-compassion by not giving into your immediate wants but focusing on your long-term well-being. My next tip is perhaps my favorite and this involves getting back to that place of passion,|||一开始总是很难的，因为我认为我们已经非常适应并习惯了熟悉和安逸的事物，对这种生活结构、生活常规的任何转变或改变都会打破这种常态。但随着时间的推移，当你适应了之后，你会发现做那些对你最好、能帮你找回热情的事情变得越来越习惯化和自动化。这其实需要你对自己表现出极大的彻底的自我同情，不要向眼前的欲望妥协，而是专注于长期的福祉。我的下一个建议可能是我最喜欢的，这涉及回到那个充满热情的地方，
interest and joy in life by creating excitement in the mundane. The biggest thing that gets me back in touch with my true self time and time again is looking for joy rather than looking for things to complain about, actively searching for things that make me happy and elated or surprised or grateful to be human rather than always buying into my negativity bias. And I do this by connecting with my inner child and getting back to a place of childhood wonder and curiosity. Your inner child is the most alive version of you there is, the least uninhibited, the most excited. And I think it's one of the saddest things about getting older is finding that everything
interest and joy in life by creating excitement in the mundane. The biggest thing that gets me back in touch with my true self time and time again is looking for joy rather than looking for things to complain about, actively searching for things that make me happy and elated or surprised or grateful to be human rather than always buying into my negativity bias. And I do this by connecting with my inner child and getting back to a place of childhood wonder and curiosity. Your inner child is the most alive version of you there is, the least uninhibited, the most excited. And I think it's one of the saddest things about getting older is finding that everything|||在平凡中创造兴奋感，从而重获生活中的兴趣和快乐。一次又一次让我重新与真实的自我建立联系的最重要的事情，是寻找快乐而不是寻找抱怨的事情，是主动寻找那些让我感到快乐、兴高采烈、感到惊讶或庆幸自己身为人类的事情，而不是总是陷入消极偏见。我是通过与内在小孩连接、回到童年的惊奇和好奇心状态来做到这一点的。你的内在小孩是你身上最具活力、最无拘无束、最兴奋的部分。我想，变老最令人悲哀的事情之一就是发现一切
becomes a lot more gray, that there is a certain glimmer that we lose that. It feels like we can't get back, but I think that we can. We can achieve that sense of wonder that we had when we were younger. By looking for things to be amazed about rather than things to be disappointed over. you know, the leaves changing color, the cat you see every day on your walk to work, eating a really tasty pastry or a tasty piece of fruit, smiling at a stranger, having them smile back, like your favorite artist, playing over the radio at the supermarket, a cool bug on a tree, singing along to like the opening track of your favorite TV show, joy really
becomes a lot more gray, that there is a certain glimmer that we lose that. It feels like we can't get back, but I think that we can. We can achieve that sense of wonder that we had when we were younger. By looking for things to be amazed about rather than things to be disappointed over. you know, the leaves changing color, the cat you see every day on your walk to work, eating a really tasty pastry or a tasty piece of fruit, smiling at a stranger, having them smile back, like your favorite artist, playing over the radio at the supermarket, a cool bug on a tree, singing along to like the opening track of your favorite TV show, joy really|||都变得暗淡无光，我们似乎失去了一种微光。感觉我们再也找不回来了，但我认为我们可以。我们可以重新获得年轻时那种惊叹的感觉。通过寻找让人惊叹的事物，而不是寻找让人失望的事物。你知道的，树叶变色了，上班路上每天都能看到的猫，吃到一块美味的点心或可口的水果，对陌生人微笑并得到对方的回应，就像你喜欢的艺术家在超市的广播里播放着歌曲，树上的一只酷炫的虫子，跟着你最喜欢的电视剧片头曲一起哼唱，快乐真的
is everywhere. And it's a strange feeling because it's one of the few emotions that when you you search for it, you'll notice that it wants you to find it, right? Like, if you look for happiness, you can't always find it, but if you look for joy, you most certainly will. As you kind of train yourself to look for awe and to discover joy, you also begin to notice that your thoughts and cognitions begin to transform and become more positive, and you slowly get that glow and appreciation for life back. Another part of getting in touch with your inner child is allowing yourself to be playful. Play is honestly so much fun. That's like the whole point, right, to just be free of everything else that's hanging over you and to get into your body, to get into your joy, to get
is everywhere. And it's a strange feeling because it's one of the few emotions that when you you search for it, you'll notice that it wants you to find it, right? Like, if you look for happiness, you can't always find it, but if you look for joy, you most certainly will. As you kind of train yourself to look for awe and to discover joy, you also begin to notice that your thoughts and cognitions begin to transform and become more positive, and you slowly get that glow and appreciation for life back. Another part of getting in touch with your inner child is allowing yourself to be playful. Play is honestly so much fun. That's like the whole point, right, to just be free of everything else that's hanging over you and to get into your body, to get into your joy, to get|||无处不在。这是一种奇怪的感觉，因为它是为数不多的几种情绪之一：当你寻找它时，你会发现它其实也渴望被你找到，对吧？就像，如果你寻找幸福，你可能不总能找到，但如果你寻找快乐，你一定能找到。当你训练自己去寻找敬畏感、去发现快乐时，你也会开始注意到自己的思想和认知开始转变，变得更加积极，你慢慢找回了那种生命的光彩和对生活的热爱。与内在小孩保持联系的另一个部分是允许自己保持玩心。玩耍老实说真的很有趣。这就像是全部的意义所在，对吧，摆脱所有悬而未决的事情，进入你的身体，进入你的快乐，进入
into the moment. And studies have really shown that play in adulthood lets us act in a way that is unstructured and creative and it reduces stress levels. It increases creativity, of course, along with the number of neural connections we have in our brain because we engage in different kinds of activities that use different parts of our brain that normally don't talk to each other. Anything you do recreationally that brings you joy or excitement counts as play.
into the moment. And studies have really shown that play in adulthood lets us act in a way that is unstructured and creative and it reduces stress levels. It increases creativity, of course, along with the number of neural connections we have in our brain because we engage in different kinds of activities that use different parts of our brain that normally don't talk to each other. Anything you do recreationally that brings you joy or excitement counts as play.|||当下。研究确实表明，成年后的玩耍能让我们以一种无结构且有创意的方式行事，并且它能降低压力水平。当然，它还能增强创造力，并增加我们大脑中的神经连接数量，因为我们参与了各种各样的活动，这些活动会用到平时互不联系的大脑不同部位。任何能带给你快乐或兴奋的娱乐活动都算作玩耍。
You know, it could be a video game. It could be playing sport, especially if it's social sport. It could be writing little poems in your spare time, painting, I don't know, trampolining, literally going on the public swing at like your local park, going for a swim at the beach. That is play. And it once again is an avenue for joy to enter your life and to keep you feeling like wonderful and curious and engaged in your environment and your surroundings rather than kind of
You know, it could be a video game. It could be playing sport, especially if it's social sport. It could be writing little poems in your spare time, painting, I don't know, trampolining, literally going on the public swing at like your local park, going for a swim at the beach. That is play. And it once again is an avenue for joy to enter your life and to keep you feeling like wonderful and curious and engaged in your environment and your surroundings rather than kind of|||你知道的，它可以是一个电子游戏。它可以是进行体育运动，尤其是社交性运动。它可以是在业余时间写写小诗，画画，我不知道，蹦床，甚至去当地公园的公共秋千上荡秋千，去海滩游泳。这就是玩耍。它再次成为快乐进入你生活的一个途径，让你始终感觉生活美妙、充满好奇心，并积极投入到你的环境和周围事物中，而不是那种
stuck behind like a glass wall of negativity, feeling like you're watching your life go by and you're not able to reach out. and touch it. I think reconnecting with that childlike version of you is a wonderful diversion from all the stresses and responsibilities that do keep us disconnected because it lets us slip back into a perspective that is so uninhibited, that is so carefree, that is so just like energized for life. I really, really implore you to try it, even if you feel embarrassed or you feel cringe. It's not about what other people think. It's about what's going to leave you feeling your best. I think the main thing here is that getting your spark back after it's been dulled isn't all
就像被一堵负面情绪的玻璃墙挡在后面，感觉自己看着生活从眼前流逝，却无能为力，无法去触碰它。我认为，重新连接那个孩童般的自己，是摆脱那些让我们感到疏离的压力和责任的一种绝妙方式，因为它能让我们重新陷入一种毫无拘束、无忧无虑、对生活充满活力的视角。我真的很恳切地请求你们去尝试一下，哪怕你觉得尴尬或难为情。这与别人的想法无关，而是关于什么能让你感觉最好。我认为这里最主要的一点是，在生活失去光彩后找回你的火花，并不完全是
internal. It's also about the external environment you create for yourself. I think partially what losing your love and energy for life comes down to is a lack of inspiration, is feeling stuck in the norm and not having new thoughts, not having new beliefs, not experiencing new sensations, new interests. I think you just become very much numb and shut. down. When life starts to feel plain and colorless, that is an invitation for you to add some color back in by keeping yourself inspired. And I love doing this by consuming content, media, books, articles, music, anything that gets your brain working and thinking and firing differently. Start your morning off, you know, with a TED talk instead of social media, with five minutes
内在的。它还关乎你为自己创造的外部环境。我认为，失去对生活的热爱和动力，部分原因在于缺乏灵感，感觉被困在常规中，没有新的想法，没有新的信念，没有体验到新的感官、新的兴趣。我想你只是变得麻木和封闭。当生活开始变得平淡和褪色时，这就是在邀请你通过保持灵感来为生活添上一抹亮色。我喜欢通过消费内容、媒体、书籍、文章、音乐、任何能让你的大脑运转、思考并以不同方式激发灵感的事物来做到这一点。你可以用TED演讲而不是社交媒体来开始你的早晨，花五分钟
of meditation instead of doom scrolling with energetic music. Have like a wild dance in your bathroom in the morning. Make that part of your routine. Listen to podcasts like this one or subscribe to like a news site like the New York Times or the Atlantic. That is $5 a month for priceless access to a world that feels a lot more expensive than your day-to-day life. To hearing about what everyone's doing across the globe.
冥想而不是刷负面新闻，配上充满活力的音乐。早上在浴室里疯狂地跳个舞。把它变成你日常的一部分。收听像这样的播客，或者订阅像《纽约时报》或《大西洋月刊》这样的新闻网站。每个月只需5美元，就能获得无价的通道，去接触一个比你的日常生活感觉丰富得多的世界，去听听全球各地人们都在做些什么。
I also want to recommend a book here that I think is in value. when you're feeling like you're in a bit of a sparkless rut. The book is called The Alchemist. I'm sure a lot of you have heard about this before. It is so widely read and known for good reason. Because even if you're not like a big reader, this novel offers such a simple, digestible, inspiring kind of folk story about getting more out of your life,
我还想在这里推荐一本书，当你觉得自己陷入了缺乏火花的沉闷 rut（死胡同）时，这本书非常有价值。这本书叫《牧羊少年奇幻之旅》（The Alchemist）。我相信你们很多人以前都听说过它。它被广泛阅读和熟知是有原因的。因为即使你不是一个爱读书的人，这本小说也提供了一个如此简单、易懂、鼓舞人心的民间故事，关于如何从生活中获得更多，
about getting more out of your dreams, out of yourself and refocusing on your purpose, on your drive. I think that's something that we lose as life gets harder as we get older. We get stuck in our routines. And of course, we lose our spark. So I read this book in like one or two sittings a few years back. And I just started rereading it. And it's incredibly eye-opening.
关于从你的梦想中、从你自己身上获得更多，并重新聚焦于你的目标、你的驱动力。我认为这是随着生活变得艰难、我们变老而失去的东西。我们陷入了常规。当然，我们失去了火花。所以几年前我花了一到两次的时间读完了这本书。我最近又开始重读它。它真的极其发人深省。
Even if you've read it before, honestly read it again. Because the message, I think, becomes different. the older you get, you interpret it differently. And I think it's really valuable to seek inspiration from other people's ideas and their articulation of their mission and their, and kind of how they see the world, whether that is the same or different to your own, at least it challenges you to think about your life differently. In fact, I think obviously, you know, reading a book is not a huge task. Expanding the media you consume is minor.
即使你以前读过它，老实说，再读一遍。因为随着你年龄的增长，我认为它的信息会变得不同，你的解读也会不同。我认为从别人的想法、他们对自己使命的阐述以及他们如何看待世界中寻求灵感是非常有价值的，无论这些与你自己的相同还是不同，至少它会挑战你以不同的方式思考你的生活。事实上，显然，读一书并不是一项艰巨的任务。扩展你接触的媒体也是微不足道的。
and listening to TED Talks is pretty easy. Seeing joy in your life is not that hard. You really only need to pick out like three things a day. And I really think that all of these things, the reason why they're so powerful is because time and time again, they make you actually engage with what's around you. They make you engage with your thoughts, with your life, rather than sitting in the passenger seat.
而且听TED演讲也相当容易。在生活中发现快乐并不是那么难。你真的只需要每天挑出三件事。我真的认为所有这些事情之所以如此强大，是因为它们一次又一次地让你真正参与到你周围的事物中。它们让你参与到你的思想中，参与到你的生活中，而不是坐在副驾驶座上。
if you've lost your spark, I would really encourage you to reflect on whether the life you're currently living actually provides you with an opportunity to be in touch with life, to be alive. Routine is really great for creating structure and bringing order and productivity into our lives, but that is not what life is. Life is what happens around that. Life is what is spontaneous and thrilling and what gives you new stories and new feelings and new energy. So I would also say break out of the monotony by really challenging yourself to do one new thing this week, one new thing every week, even if that's alone, a new gym class, a new part of the city to explore a new dish that you're going to cook for yourself. New things are good for our emotional health because it actually really opens up our mind, I think, to the possibility of more.
如果你失去了生活的热情，我真的鼓励你反思一下，你目前过的生活是否真的为你提供了一个与生活保持联系、去体验活着的契机。常规对于建立秩序、为我们的生活带来秩序和生产力确实非常棒，但那并不是生活。生活是这一切之外发生的事情。生活是那些自发的、惊险刺激的、能给你带来新故事、新感觉和新能量的东西。所以我也想说，通过真正挑战自己在本周做一件新事来打破单调，每周做一件新事，即使是一个人去上新的健身课，去探索城市的一个新区域，或者为自己做一道新菜。新鲜事物对我们的情绪健康有好处，因为我认为它实际上极大地开拓了我们对更多可能性的认知。
Like they've done research on this and the happiest people are those who really expose themselves to new things, who challenge the norm, who challenge their brains to think about things differently. Because novelty also introduces excitement. There is a really great article by Psychology Today that puts it like this. When we try something new, this actually opens up the possibility for you to enjoy something new. there have been entire careers, entire life paths carved out by people dipping their baby toes into small ponds and suddenly discovering a love for something they had no idea would capture their imaginations. It forces you to grow, it forces you to choose to live light by kind of living heavy.
就像他们对此做过研究一样，最快乐的人是那些真正让自己接触新事物的人，是那些挑战常规、挑战大脑以不同方式思考问题的人。因为新鲜感也会带来兴奋。《今日心理学》上有一篇非常棒的文章，它是这样表达的：当我们尝试新事物时，这实际上为我们享受新事物开启了可能性。曾有整个职业生涯、整个人生道路，都是由那些把脚趾伸进小水塘里，突然发现自己热爱上某种从未想过会激发想象力的人开辟出来的。它迫使你成长，它迫使你通过背负重担来选择轻松地生活。
And I think that you just bear witness to the parts of your identity that are allowed to kind of flourish. in those moments where life isn't like easy, life isn't familiar, the moment that you're in, you might not be comfortable, but it's there that your spark really returns because you have to rely on yourself. And you have to really pull from this pool of just innate joy and energy and capability. I think it's a better way to put it. All right, I have two final tips for you and we're going to keep them short and sweet. The first is to be practice. some form of movement every day. Now this is not movement to lose weight. It's not movement to get fitter. It's not for a beauty standard, but it's because of what it will do for your brain. Now I really
而且我认为，你只是见证了你身份中那些被允许在生活中不那么轻松、不那么熟悉的时刻蓬勃发展的那些部分，你所在的时刻可能并不舒适，但正是在那里，你的火花真正回归了，因为你必须依靠自己。你必须真正从这种纯粹的快乐、能量和能力池中汲取力量。我想这样表达会更好。好了，我最后有两个建议给你们，我们会简短而甜美。第一是每天练习某种形式的运动。现在，这不是为了减肥而进行的运动。这不是为了变得更健美而进行的运动。这不是为了迎合审美标准，而是因为这会对你的大脑产生影响。现在我真的
despise when people say that exercise is some like magical cure for mental health problems. That's literally bullshit. But we are seeing research that shows how protective physical activity is for these kinds of ruts or periods of depletion we might find ourselves in. There's actually a really special research project that was conducted in Australia by the University of Sydney, literally down the road from where I am right now. And it published findings that unstructured dance, so not dance for the purpose of exercise even for getting your heart rate up, literally just dancing around your living room, dancing around wherever you are. It's actually one of the best things you can do for your brain and mental well-being. Besides that, exercise boosts mental energy, it boosts motivation. Those are two things that are really crucial for getting our spark back.
鄙视那些把锻炼说成是什么精神健康问题神奇解药的人。那简直是胡扯。但我们看到的研究表明，体育活动对于我们可能发现自己陷入的这种沉闷或精疲力竭的时期具有多么强的保护作用。事实上，澳大利亚悉尼大学进行了一个非常特殊的的研究项目，就在离我现在所在地不远的地方。它公布的研究结果表明，非结构化舞蹈，即不是为了锻炼目的甚至不是为了提高心率的舞蹈，字面意思就是只在你的客厅里、无论你在哪里的周围跳舞。这实际上你能为你的大脑和心理健康做的最好的事情之一。除此之外，运动能提升精神能量，提升动力。这两点对于我们找回火花至关重要。
I think it's especially impactful and special if you find time to move in nature. There is a whole field of research called eco-psychology that talks about how spending time outdoors promotes how we feel about ourselves and our lives and the attitudes we bring into our day to day. You probably already know this without me needing to tell you. You know, just think about how good you feel after you take a swim in the ocean. Have you ever felt bad after a swim in the ocean? After a hike? After you walked by the creek near your house?
我认为，如果你能找到时间在自然环境中运动，那将特别有影响力和特别。有一个专门的研究领域叫环境心理学，它探讨了花时间在大自然中如何促进我们对自我、生活的感受以及我们带入日常生活的态度。你可能不需要我告诉你就已经知道了。你知道的，只要想想你在海洋里畅游之后感觉有多好。你在海洋里畅游后感觉糟糕过吗？在徒步旅行之后？在你走过家附近的小溪之后？
That's where humans are meant to be. So it's no wonder that we're losing our vibrancy and our spark and our love for life when we are living in a world that is focused on keeping us inside. I think nature provides a lot of healing in that sense for reconnecting ourselves with what it truly means to be human, what it truly means to be alive in our bodies, how capable our bodies are, how much feeling our bodies can hold. That's spark. That is spark right there. Embracing what makes us wild.
那是人类本该在的地方。所以难怪当我们生活在一个专注于把我们关在室内世界里时，我们会失去活力、火花和对生活的热爱。我认为大自然在某种意义上提供了很多治愈，让我们重新与作为真正人类的意义、在身体里活着的真正意义、我们的身体有多大能力、我们的身体能容纳多少情感重新连接。这就是火花。火花就在那里。拥抱让我们野性的一面。
Embracing the beauty of the outdoors, the beauty of what comes from that. And kind of watching how you're, I don't know, it's just. just instantly fills up your cup and it keeps it full for days even weeks after. A final tip, I think, try to spend less time thinking about what others have that you don't and think about everything that is wonderful about your life and what you have. What are your own secret gardens? I speak about this a lot, but this is a concept I came up with. A while back that essentially says each of us has this like secret part of who we are
拥抱户外的美丽，拥抱由此产生的美好。然后看着你的，我不知道，它只是瞬间填满你的杯子，并在接下来的几天甚至几周里让它保持满载。最后一个建议，我认为，尽量少去想别人有什么而你没有，多去想想关于你的生活和拥有什么是美好的。什么是你自己的秘密花园？我经常谈论这个，但这是我前段时间想出的一个概念，本质上是说我们每个人内心深处都有这样一部分
locked in the back of our mind that I call our secret garden. And our secret garden is filled with the things that are special, unique, vulnerable, entirely ours. It could be, you know, the little hobby that you haven't told anybody about. The little passion project that is just yours. Your deep dives on Wikipedia, the poetry you write in your notes app. The fact that you still love music from the early 2000s. The fact that actually you're a really good singer, you just don't sing in front of other people, that you can make a really good lasagna or a really good birthday cake.
锁在我们心智的后方，我称之为我们的秘密花园。而我们的秘密花园里充满了那些特殊、独特、脆弱且完全属于我们自己的东西。它可能是，你知道的，你没有告诉任何人的小爱好。那个完全属于你的微型热情项目。你在维基百科上的深入研究，你在备忘录应用里写的诗。事实上，你仍然喜欢2000年代初的音乐。事实上，其实你是个很好的歌手，只是不在别人面前唱歌，你能做出非常棒的千层面或非常棒的生日蛋糕。
Those are parts of your secret garden. They are what makes it special, what makes us happy, and we need to spend time in that garden. We need to water it. We need to share its kind of bounty with others. And you'll notice how much more alive and connected you feel. when you spend less time looking over the fence at someone else's life and more time really like appreciating what you have and also just seeking to elevate that seeking to be grateful but also seeking to build it even further not for somebody else not so that they think you're
这些都是你秘密花园的一部分。它们让它变得特别，让我们快乐，我们需要花时间在那座花园里。我们需要给它浇水。我们需要与他人分享它的丰硕成果。你会注意到，当你花更少的时间去窥探别人的生活，而花更多的时间去真正欣赏你所拥有的，并试图提升它、学会感恩、甚至进一步构建它时，你会感觉自己是多么生机勃勃、充满联系——不是为了别人，不是为了让他们觉得你
accomplished or cool or whatever it is but because you actually want amazing things to come your way. You want a life that you feel happy with. You want your spark back. Like that's the entire point of this episode. You want to feel like there is a fire that you have in your stomach for life. So I want to finish off by saying, I'm really glad that you are here if you're feeling this way. I feel you. I know this rut feels like it will last a lifetime. Like you'll never be that kind of fun person you were three, four, five years ago. And you know what? You probably won't be that person. again, but you are discovering and building somebody better. You will feel excited by life again. You will fall back in love with yourself again. I just think that it requires a bit of a holistic
很有成就感或很酷或诸如此类的，而是因为你确实希望美好的事情降临到你身上。你想要一个让你感到快乐的生活。你想要找回你的火花。就像这是这集的全部意义所在。你希望感觉你的胃里对生活还有一团火。所以我想在最后说，如果你有这种感觉，我真的很高兴你能来到这里。我感同身受。我知道这种死气沉沉的感觉就像会持续一辈子。就像你永远不会再成为三、四年、五年前那个有趣的人。你知道吗？你可能真的不会再成为那个人了，但你正在发现并构建一个更好的人。你将再次对生活感到兴奋。你将再次重新爱上你自己。我只是觉得这需要一点整体性的
change. It's really normal, I think, for us to find ourselves at this point of just like shallowness and hollowness and emptiness. That's kind of part of the journey, right? It's about rebuilding the things that we have perhaps been neglecting. It's about being kind of exhilarated. by the mundane. It's about creating habits for your life that it's going to mean that you still feel vibrant and alive, even if you're behind a desk, working nine to five for the rest of your life. Even if you're stressed, even if you're overwhelmed, there is so much more to life than commitment, so much more to life than responsibility than what other people think, than what you even think. There's a lot of beauty hiding in, I think, the everyday and hiding in our commitment
改变。我认为，我们发现自己处于这种肤浅、空虚和虚无的时刻是非常正常的。这可以说是旅程的一部分，对吧？这是关于重建那些我们可能一直在忽视的事物。这是关于对平凡感到兴奋。这是关于为你的生活创造各种习惯，这意味着即使你在余生中都坐在办公桌前朝九晚五地工作，你依然会感到充满活力和生机。即使你压力山大，即使你不知所措，生活中也有比责任多得多的东西，比其他人的想法多得多的东西，甚至比你自己的想法多得多的东西。我认为，有许多美丽隐藏在日常生活中，隐藏在我们对自己的承诺以及向自己展现的爱中，这些真正点燃了我们，真正点燃了我们腹中的火焰，让我们渴望成功、美好、充满喜悦地生活。
and the love that we show ourselves that really sets us a light that really sparks a fire in our belly to want to live successfully and beautifully and filled with joy. So I just really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I really hope that you've got something out of it. I really hope that you are like on your path to getting your spark back, whether you've lost it because of a breakup, because you've been burnt out, because of whatever it is. You'll have. You'll have. find your way back and I hope this will help you do that. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. I actually really enjoyed this. I'm going to be applying some of these strategies. Obviously,
所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我真的希望你从中有所收获。我真的希望你正走在找回火花的路上，无论你是因为失恋、精疲力竭还是其他原因而失去了它。你会找到回归之路，我希望这能帮你做到这一点。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方给我们留下五星评价。我其实真的很享受这个。我将应用其中一些策略。显然，
I already do, but I'm really trying to bring more of this into my life. I feel like I've lost my own way a little bit. Happens to the best of us. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast or at Gemma Speg if you want to see more behind the scenes content see what's coming out we actually have something really special coming out in the next month so if you've made it this far i guess you're the first to know i'm not going to tell you exactly what it is but keep your eyes peeled because yeah i'm really excited about it and i hope you are too we will of course be back for another episode next week. Until then, be gentle with yourself. Be kind to yourself and stay safe. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
我已经在做了，但我真的很想把更多这些带入我的生活。我觉得我自己有点迷失了方向。这种情况在所难免。如果你想看到更多幕后内容并了解即将推出什么，请务必在Instagram上关注我们：@thatpsychologypodcast 或 @gemmaspeg，我们下个月其实会推出一些非常特别的东西，所以如果你坚持听到了这里，我想你是第一批知道的人。我不会确切告诉你那是什么，但请拭目以待，因为是的，我对此真的很兴奋，我希望你也是。我们当然会在下周的另一集中回归。在此之前，对自己温柔一点。善待自己，保持安全。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hardway》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和培养抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将作为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
这就是在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。听听女友们的经历。
Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
相信我，宝贝，在Iheart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个大时刻。对大卫来说84年很大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild... I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
并试图理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的……我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证由真人创作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。